[Music]
at a later time the Persian king para
seas became involved in a war
concerning boundaries with the nation of
the Ethel eighty Huns
were called white Huns parody's gathered
an imposing army and marched against
them
the Apfel eighty are one of the stock of
the Huns in fact as well as in name
however they do not mingle with any of
the Huns known to us for they occupy
land
neither adjoining nor even very near to
them but their territory lies
immediately to the north of Persia
indeed their city called Gorgo is
located over against the Persian
frontier and is consequently the center
of frequent contests concerning boundary
lines between the two peoples for they
are not nomads like the other Chanukah
peoples but for a long period have been
established in a goodly land as a result
of this they have never made any
incursion into the Roman territory
except in company with the median army
they are the only ones amongst the Huns
who have white bodies and countenances
which are not ugly it is also true that
their manner of living is unlike that of
their kinsmen nor do they live a savage
life as they do but they are ruled by
one king and since they possess a lawful
Constitution they observe right and
justice in their dealings both with one
another and with their neighbors in no
degree less than the Romans and the
Persians
moreover the wealthy citizens are in the
habit of attaching to themselves friends
to the number of 20 or more as the case
may be and these become permanently
their banquet companions and have a
share in all of their property enjoying
some kind of a common right in this
matter then when the man who has
gathered such a company together comes
to die it is the custom at all these men
be born alive into the tomb with him
parodies marching against these Ethel 80
was accompanied by an ambassador you say
be us by name who as it happened had
been sent to his court by the Emperor
Zeno now the epital a tea made it appear
to their enemy that they had turned to
flight because they were wholly
terrified by their attack and they
retired with all speed to a place which
was shut on every side by precipitous
mountains and abundantly screamed by a
closed forest of wide spreading trees
now as one advanced between the
mountains to a great distance a broad
way appeared in the valley extending
apparently to an indefinite distance
but at the end it had no outlet at all
but terminated in the very midst of the
circle of mountains so parodies with no
thought at all of treachery and
forgetting that he was marching in a
hostile country continued the pursuit
without the least caution a small body
of the Huns were in flight before him
while the greater part of their force by
concealing themselves in the rough
country got in the rear of the hostile
army but as they yet desired not to be
seen by them in order that they might
advance well into the trap and get as
far as possible in amongst the mountains
and those be no longer able to turn back
when the Meads began to realize all this
for they now began to have a glimmering
of their peril though they refrained
from speaking of the situation
themselves through fear of parodies yet
they earnestly entreated you say be asst
to urge upon the king who was completely
ignorant of his own plight that he
should take counsel rather than make an
untimely display of daring and consider
well whether there was any way of safety
open to them so he went before parodies
but by no means revealed the calamity
which was upon them instead he began
with a fable telling how a lion once
happened upon a goat bound down and
bleating on a mound of no very great
height and how the lion bent upon making
a feast of the goat rushed forward with
intent to seize him but fell into a
trench exceedingly deep in which was a
circular path narrow and endless for it
had no outlet anywhere which indeed the
owners of the goat had constructed for
this very purpose and they had placed
the goat above it to be a bait for the
lion
when parodies heard this a fear came
over him lest perchance the Medes had
brought harm upon themselves by their
pursuit of the enemy he therefore
advanced no further but remaining where
he was began to consider the situation
by this time the Huns were following him
without any concealment and regarding
the entrance of the place in order that
their enemy might no longer be able to
withdraw to the rear then at last the
Persians saw clearly in what straits
they were and they felt that the
situation was desperate for they had no
hope that they would ever escaped from
the peril
then the king of the Advil 80 cents some
of his followers to parodies he
unbraided him at length for his
senseless full hardiness by which he had
wantedly destroyed both himself and the
Persian people but he announced that
even so the Huns would grant him
deliverance
if parodies should consent to restraint
himself before him as having proved
himself master and taking the oaths
traditional among the Persians should
give pledges that they would never again
take the field against the nation of the
epital 80
[Music]
when parodies heard this he had a
consultation with the Magi who were
present and inquired of them whether he
must comply with the terms dictated by
the enemy the mage I replied that as to
the oath he should settle the matter
according to his own pleasure as for the
rest however he should circumvent his
enemy by craft and they reminded him
that it was the custom among the
Persians to prostrate themselves before
the Rising Sun each day he should
therefore watch the time closely and
meet the leader of the epilady at dawn
and then turning toward the Rising Sun
make his obeisance in this way they
explained he would be able in the future
to escape the ignominy of the deed
heresies accordingly gave the pledges
concerning the peace and frustrated
himself before his folk exactly as the
mage I had suggested and so with the
whole median army intact gladly retired
Holmwood
you
[Music]
you